die schweiz ein land in dem man gerne
lebt
ein land in dem eigentlich alles
funktioniert
viele menschen tragen im hintergrund
dazu bei
ricardo moreno ist sprengmeister mehr
cadenazzo ist ja fitting
claude berri ist feuerwehrmann und
christine fässler ist hebamme
wie leben diese menschen wofür setzen
sie sich ein
und was beschäftigt sie vier menschen
und ihr alltag ein tag im leben der
schweiz
im juni morgens um 4
ricardo hat morgenschicht er arbeitet am
chenery basistunnel
halb fünf im gotthardgebiet auch bär
steht früh auf und mit ihr viele der
acht millionen menschen in der schweiz
ricardo muss sich bald eine neue arbeit
suchen
claude wird bald heiraten
jedes leben ist verschieden jede
geschichte besonders
ricardo ist die italiener wie die
meisten hier seit 13 jahren arbeitet er
für die nähert man geht hinein macht
eine arbeit und gilt wieder hinaus sechs
kilometer müssen sie bis zur spreng
stelle zurück liegen 15 4 kilometer
tunnel werden am chenery gebaut
wir haben hier viel schweiß verloren
sehr viel spaß hier sind die bedingungen
nicht wirklich gesund aber weißt du was
man gewöhnt sich dran
es ist 6 schicht übergabe 700 meter
unter der erde
auf dem berg zur selben zeit
wer wohnt im wohnwagen hinter der
kiesgrube von hosston tal
sie führt mit ihrer familie ein
einfaches leben in münchenstein basel
claude ist feuerwehrmann seine freundin
barbara sanitäterin in einer woche
wollen die beiden heiraten
funktioniert die hochzeit das ist ganz
klar
er steht wieder die traditionelle
theaterstück sich absichern falls ihm
etwas geschieht hat sie angst wenn im
einsatz ist
es ist halb sieben die fest lassen
schmid hatten eine unruhige nacht
christine ist noch müde sie ist eine von
rund 1.170 freiberuflichen hebammen in
der schweiz
ich bin dank und wo geburtstag vom hat
da bin ich von bioware kabinett
fahrstunde xxi und ja das wird so sieht
es das handy hüpft ballt in den bergen
sind mittlerweile auch bei uns kinder
wach ja man michi ist schon am 1
die 14 jährige männer geht in die
oberstufe der zwölfjährige mauro besucht
die primarschule und sein neunjähriger
bruder nando ebenso die primarschule war
bisher in horsten teil aber immer mehr
familien ziehen weg
die schule beginnt um 8 sie ist
zweieinhalb kilometer entfernt
antritts appell auf der feuerwehrwache
in basel
pro schicht sind 24 feuerwehrmänner im
einsatz
sie dauert 24 stunden jeder hat seine
aufgabe
das material muss laufend kontrolliert
werden frauen gibt es hier keine
im channel bereitet ricardo die nächste
explosion vor
ja
aber dabei
ich organisiere alles was es braucht das
heißt ich organisiere die arbeit und ich
muss die probleme lösen
zudem muss er sich um den papierkram
kümmern
bis zum durchstich dauert es nicht mehr
lange
wir sind bei 6.800 74 meter und wir
müssen bis 7772 kommen so fehlen
ungefähr 900 meter
zwei bis drei mal pro tag wird gesprengt
dazu müssen sie nun löcher für die
sprengladung boden
mein ziel ist es zu sprengen wenn du
strengen kannst ist es ein schöner tag
manchmal kannst du aus dem einen oder
anderen grund nicht sprengen und dann
musst du den fernzünder der nächsten
mannschaft übergeben
den knall der explosion nicht zuhören
fertig habt ihr den tag
wir strengen um 5.11 wenn du mich
brauchst mich und dann würde ich doch
einfach mal verbieten will die anwältin
amateuren die lose und wenn du mich
vorher bescheid nicht dass kurz auf
christines mann josef hat heute
meerschweinchen morgen dienst
jeder tag ist anders mit einer hebamme
im haus sie sehr selbstständig als
partner direkt in die freiheit
doch
ich bin dir hoch ist hat sich sehr
schmal und erich
wenn ich das gar nicht so klar
sie geht so süß wirklicher familie wie
ich das verstanden habe ich völlig in
einer anderen situation
und trotzdem mittlerweile haben sie zwei
söhne
wer ist auf dem weg zu schaffen
etwa 220 hirten gibt es in der schweiz
zurzeit hütet sie 1330 schafe von
verschiedenen bauern ein paar eigene
ziegen und schafe hält sie selbst
menge spaß heute mal sie ja selber
findet
wo ist seine mutter bloß und was
passiert wenn wir sie nicht findet es
ist 10
solange kein alarm losgeht üben die
feuerwehrleute verschiedene manöver eine
luft rettungsübung claude muss eine
verletzte person aus einem schacht
bergen angst hatte nicht wenn dafür
dennis völlig natürliche angst ist
negativ damit dass ich am meisten regen
in die 2 von körper oder vor einem saal
boden seite durch der migranten vom
helden image hält er nicht viel
wir sind keine helden behält und mit
jeder brief gar nicht und ich möchte da
damit dass ein vermittler
ich bin pro woche eine person wurde in
einer notsituation ist und jeden und
alle meine kameraden viel schlimmer
das mikro
allein nun gilt es einst im reihen ist
jemandem ertrinken
die feuerwehr ist auch für diese
rettungen zuständig
alles muss schnell gehen die
überlebenschancen sinken
drei junge asylbewerber aus eritrea sind
bei 35 grad hitze ins wasser gesprungen
einer hat den ausstieg nicht mehr
geschafft es wird schnell klar dass man
ihn nur noch tot bergen können
das
absolut
das effektive nicht sein
verbieten
deutsche und franzosen helfen mit aber
der einsatzleiter muss aufgeben
eine traurige realität
jeder geht unterschiedlich damit um
claude will nicht darüber reden die
meisten rettungsaktionen sind jedoch
erfolgreich
jedes jahr sterben aber trotzdem drei
bis vier menschen hier im rhein
kurz vor 11 die 100 löcher sind gebohrt
nun werden die sprengladung
hineingeschoben
die arbeit ist gefährlich bisher wurden
beim nährt bei neun menschen getötet
alle hier sind aufeinander angewiesen
fehler liegen nicht drin
allein ist mir wichtig
es schlage sich
in zehn minuten sprenge ich
für jede sprengung braucht es zwischen
100 und 300 kilogramm sprengstoff
bis sich der staub und die gase verzogen
haben müssen die arbeiter im container
waren trotz routine jede sprengung ist
ein highlight
ok
christine besucht vor der anstehenden
geburt eine wöchnerin mit ihrem baby
ramon ist vor sechs tagen zur welt
gekommen jeden tag werden in der schweiz
durchschnittlich 233 babys geboren
tendenz steigend und das ist im fall
megacool rahmens mutter kann nicht still
christine gibt ja ein paar tipps das
licht an und versucht zu wechseln prüft
sind zwei teams die schwach zum links
und das hat noch damit nur mit der
verbindung von den beiden hälften der
linken
auf der weide oberhalb von osten tal
einem der schafe geht es nicht gut
antibiotika sind alltag auch auf der
schafe hüten liegt im trend die zahl der
hirten hat sich in den letzten zehn
jahren verdoppelt auf der feuerwehrwache
ist wieder routine eingekehrt
die männer kochen zusammen aber aus dem
essen wird nicht der nächste alarm geht
los
bei einem eco
2500 mal im jahr rückt die basler
feuerwehr mit blaulicht aus diesmal ist
in einem einfamilienhaus quartier ein
feuer ausgebrochen
alles halb so wild ein hauseigentümer
hat versucht mit dem bunsenbrenner
ungeziefer in einem alten baum störung
zu vertilgen
und das bei 35 grad im schatten
kein wunder ist der baumstamm in brand
geraten eigentlich müsste man ihn fällen
aber der besitzer hält ihn für ein
kunstwerk und möchte ihn retten der
mottbrand muss gelöscht werden wenn
zugleich weltweit sind überbewertet
wenn mich persönlich ein empfehlen dass
auch ich mir in der schweiz mehr
wir sind definitiv sich technisch extrem
viel und das ist schon toll ist auch an
der luxus war in der schweiz definitiv
es gibt 1100 berufsfeuerwehrleute zeit
banale freiwilligen dazu sind es über
90.000
mittagszeit im mittelland
auch wenn die schweiz im europäischen
vergleich immer noch das schlusslicht
ist der einfamilienhaus markt boomt
mittlerweile besitzen 37 prozent der
menschen wohneigentum auch die fans
haben ein haus
christine und ihre beiden jungs warten
auf josef
josef hat sein eigenes geschäft und
kommt über mittag heinz geworden sind
wird jetzt mit alt miteinander ganz
ausgemacht
und dann ist für diese einfach auch mehr
macht pause sie ist auf einem kleinen
bauernhof in davos aufgewachsen und
wollte immer schon auf die 1
bevor die kinder kamen zog sie mit ihrem
mann als vander hielt ihn herum
nun bleibt sie im winter ein hospital
und er zieht alleine los
ricardos begeistert
hast du gesehen wie schön der fels
heraus geschnitten ist
vier meter sind sie vorangekommen die
schicht ist zu ende
mir gefällt ist das ist eine arbeit die
mich zufrieden macht ich habe auch
draußen gearbeitet zum beispiel als
chauffeur aber mir passt das klima noch
im tunnel hast doch immer die gleiche
temperatur
das licht ist immer gleich wenn man
gewohnt ist drinnen zu arbeiten dann ist
so schwierig draußen
du kannst dich nicht so einfach
ungerührt im kanton schwyz rückt der
geburtstermin er die wehen sind stärker
geworden
manuela und sandro bekommen die erstes
kind die werden der großmutter hilft mit
geburtstag
gott und welt
noch dauert es claude und seine kollegen
auf dem weg zu einem neuen einsatz
keinerlei darum sind sie ohne sirene
unterwegs
sie wurden von einem alten mann gerufen
offenbar hat sich im kamin seines
estrichs ein vogel fällt ein mauersegler
auch für kleine sich die feuerwehrleute
zeit
mauersegler brauchen zwölf meter
fallhöhe um losfliegen zu können
happy
warten
wer's man mich und die kinder sind hoch
gekommen und haben salz mit gebracht die
kinder müssen oft mithelfen wenn sie
frei haben und es gibt gleich weiter
einmal pro woche kriegen die schafe
seien auch busreisen mögen das gerne
es ist halb drei jetzt braucht es
momente pause bis ich gut trainiert und
noch eines ganzen sachen
eigentlich kommen
nach jeder geburt ist dass es wohl drei
sonnen fixfertige man schon oft wald
rund wo funktioniert und was jedes
körperteil ist das so einfach machte
sich was dass ich es 100 ein junges
elternpaar glück bekam hingegen ist
traurig für dich ist es ein schöner tag
du bist fertig hier
du gehst weg die nähert ist bald fertig
gebaut
ricardos bester freund mariano hatte
norwegen eine neue arbeit gefunden
sie müssen sich trennen
männerfreundschaften sind hier eine art
familienersatz
für mich ist die familie alles ich
arbeite für sie und ich sehne mich
danach wieder runter zu gehen
alle sind dort meine kinder meine frau
alles was ich in meinem leben gutes
gemacht habe ist in sizilien
aber was in italien verdienen würden
reicht nicht um ihre familie zu ernähren
die arbeit hier erfüllt sie mit stolz
diese tunnels nach unser verdienst
diese löcher sind die zukunft der welt
es sind wichtige bauwerke wenn du denkst
dass hier in diesem tunnelabschnitt
irgendwann ganz viele menschen durch
gefahren sein werden und wir alle nicht
mehr sind und zu wissen dass wir den
durchstich gemacht haben ganz am anfang
das ist ein unbeschreibliches gefühl
eine befriedigung darüber werden wir
noch lange reden
der abschied fällt schwer
aber sie wollen den kontakt bleiben
vielleicht sehen sie sich hier ein
norwegen wieder es wäre schön wenn ich
den durchstich noch erleben könnte
ich möchte die andere seite sehen aber
ich weiß nicht wie senden wird der
besucher eine arbeit und wenn ich eine
finde dann gehe ich weil ich nicht bis
zum letzten moment warten auf der alb
hat wie er noch ein zweites lämmchen
gefunden
ein happy end
zumindest für dieses kleine hier
das andere nicht mehr mit ins tal
gut
wer hat das überleben es ist 6 christine
ist ganz beglückt nicht immer läuft es
so glatt
und was hält sie vom neuesten trend dass
frauen ganz allein sogar ohne hebamme
gewähren wollen finden ich konnte damals
mutig ich finds ehrensache bedanke mich
oder so verschaffen
vorliegend aber wichtig um über sich
selber oder ein partner wurde an der
beach und dann halt einfach die
situation als manager einen großen
überblick behindert
in seinem zimmer in der baracke
telefoniert ricardo mit seiner frau
ciao ciao
ich bin zwar weit weg aber ich versuche
nahe zu sein
leider können wir mit dieser arbeit die
familie nicht am gleichen ort haben wir
müssen uns zufrieden geben mit dem was
wir haben
das ist meine tochter francesca wir
telefonieren drei vier mal am tag
das ist auch richtig so führt man die
distanz wenig mein haus ist hier das ist
meine erde dort fühle ich mich war jedes
mal wenn ich zurückkomme
ich fühle mich einfach zu hause ricardo
ist um 4 auf gestanden
zeit zum schlafen jetzt
viertel vor acht in basel die
feuerwehrmänner sind den ganzen tag
nicht zum essen gekommen
jetzt wird endlich krepiert einziger
fisch aus dem essen wird wieder nichts
nochmals ein einsatz auf dem rhein
in den bergen gibt es nacht zuerst für
das neue waisenkind es wäre wichtig dass
das kleine lämmchen trinken würde es
gelingen kann ochs
ripley
erleichterung auch auf dem rhein keine
menschenrettung diesmal nur ein steak im
wasser offenbar von vandalen in den
rhein gekippt
das problem ist schnell behoben
ich lese schreiben holik um die sonne
heraus und bekannten erstochen
wer und mischen haben ihr einfaches
leben in den bergen mit den kindern aus
überzeugung gewählt
was sie dann auch
ab ins bett es ist schon viertel
vorziehen
christine erledigt büroarbeit manchmal
macht sie sich ein bisschen sorgen um
die neugeborenen kinder und darüber was
alles auf sie zukommt in dieser welt
statt für gesellschaft ist es wichtig
dass man akzeptiert so wie man sich das
braucht nur du studiert die lützow man
braucht wirklich alt war der basis
geschaffen das in ein altersheim mit
alter ego spazieren dass man das mit dir
genauso wertschätzt und und und und
achtet wir ein studierter pro fass
13 mal sind die feuerwehrleute heute
ausgerückt endlich gibt es etwas
zwischen die zähne die spiels lee
allerdings sind trocken geworden in der
zwischenzeit
so eng zusammenleben nicht mehr viele
menschen in der schweiz aber alle
behütet von gott glaubt mir
er schützt mich und begleitet mich zu
jeder zeit wie tag und nacht
christine und josef hoffen auf eine
ruhige nacht
klotz schicht dauert noch bis morgen
früh um 7
stoffe die man eigentlich nicht
jetzt heißt intensiver formuliert
löschen oder orte wie lange das muss
spätestens morgen steht er wieder auf
und mit ihm acht millionen andere
menschen in der schweiz jeder mit seinem
alltag und mit seiner geschichte nächste
woche
training lernt sie gibt asylsuchenden
ein dach über dem kopf
rolf bischof berger sorgt für gute laune
auf dem bauernmarkt laudehr im hof fährt
für die sp den menschen durch die
schweiz und kassel huskies hat eine
tellerwäscher karriere gemacht